when I first saw Khan Academy what was
what was attractive to me was the
ability for students to learn concepts
at their own pace when they were ready
for them and it brings that learning to
students both in the classroom and at
home with a seamless transition from one
location to the next what caught our eye
in using it to differentiate instruction
is that interface that the students have
and really on the back end all of the
complex data that's provided to the
teachers it would take them hours to get
that same kind of data it was easy to
roll out thankfully I have some teachers
who are just great risk takers and saw
the potential of how it would help their
students cost-wise is great I know there
are other math programs out there that
you can purchase but it is a costume
it's not real time the datasets the Khan
Academy provides allows principals at
the school site level to have
conversations with their teachers about
progress students are making to
recognize very quickly which students
are grasping skills and moving ahead
which students are struggling with a
particular concept and which students
are stuck and need some additional
intervention Khan Academy is directly
helping because every day every child
has the opportunity to have
individualized learning opportunities
where they are specifically working at
their level being provided with
instantaneous feedback which is not
something that they would get in the
traditional teacher lecturer model I see
every student utterly engaged in what
they're doing
and they are talking about math they are
excited about math they're appropriately
challenged and those kids who are really
math superstars are able to push
themselves to where they want to be the
parent involvement aspect is important
as well because they can actually see
the teaching the instruction as the
student here's the instruction in class
as well because they too can watch the
videos it brings an opportunity into the
home for parents to have conversations
with their children about math about
learning
and about what they're doing in school
I'm most excited that our kids are happy
and excited about learning and
especially learning math because it
seems to be the older you get in grades
you either have determined for yourself
that you love math or you're not good at
math and so if kids can have success at
their level to build that mental math
capability I think that's amazing when
both teachers and students are excited
about the teaching and learning going on
in the classroom it it has limitless
possibilities
you